[Music]
you're listening to inside of you with
michael rosenbaum i hope you uh are
enjoying your week i hope you're being
good to yourself ryan have you been good
to yourself i have been good to myself
good are you doing anything for yourself
this week are you exercising you do
anything anything good happened to you
softball i hit four for four four for
four
that means four at bats folks four hits
i played goalie in my soccer league so
these things are back which is nice this
is nice you're getting you're getting
outside i know it's crazy i like that i
hope you guys are getting outside and
thank you for tuning in if you're here
for bobby lee i i really hope bobby and
i are good friends and i hope you'll
stick around and support the podcast
and subscribe um you can follow us on
our handles ryan uh inside to be pod on
twitter at insiderviewpodcast on
instagram and facebook that's correct
and uh if you love uh i wanna shout out
to my patrons who support the podcast in
many ways and we'll get right back right
into this uh podcast in a second but if
you want to join patreon it's a
wonderful way to support the podcast in
other ways help us out go to patreon
p-a-t-r-e-o-n patreon.com inside of you
also this coming weekend um i will be in
denver colorado at the denver con for
halloween for the 30th and 31st with tom
welling so get your tickets come see us
for halloween we are taking our
halloween on the road to denver and also
i'll be at the la
um comic-con
on december 4th and 5th right here in
los angeles also if you want to buy
anything at the inside of you online
store do so we've got tons of great
stuff also lex luthor and smallville
[ __ ] we've got uh if you go to
sunspin.com you could uh buy some band
merch as you know stephen amell loves
our hats our sunspin hats we're almost
out of those hats but you can get
beanies and a bunch of other stuff as
well but i just want to say thank you
for all all of you for tuning in
bobby levin and i have been friends for
a long time he always gets open and deep
and personal and he's uh charming as
hell i i really enjoyed this podcast i
always love him having love having him
on i like to give him [ __ ] he gives me
more [ __ ] um so without further ado
let's uh get inside of bobby lee it's my
point of view
you're listening to inside of you with
michael rosenbaum
[Music]
inside of you with michael rosenbaum was
not recorded in front of a live studio
audience are you sure you didn't paint
your house it feels like i added this
wall here and i you know you know the
wall but even when i go walk into the
living room it's like a different vibe
is it a good vibe you seem like it's not
no it's uh
i always had a perception of your house
in my mind with that because i hated it
oh god like it's it's like a uh it's
something that jim henson would live in
or whatever
you know i mean like well you create
like i mean
felt you know
puppets why do you think that is why do
you think that's like because of the
because of the no it's the decor like
it's a museum
the wood it just feels like some
old-timey 1970s guy but then when i
walked in at this time
it was like um
it felt
fun like uh
moriarty's
house
you know fun
well not moriarty's house wouldn't be
fun it would be um
he's up to no good but it just has this
like 19 1800s 1800s now we're back
let's go further back yeah 1800s guy who
like is trying to foil
you know sherlock holmes
so i don't know whether you like it the
house or not i like that because i like
i do movies that have that
vibe to it kind of a not noir but kind
of an old school feel
i wouldn't live here
okay well i've been to your house i mean
i like your house which one the new one
okay i've been there did you forget i
was there
mm-hmm you did i don't i don't get to
talk to you very much
you're you're becoming how this happened
what go on
well i think
you texted me a couple weeks ago about
hey can you get paulie shore yeah i
thought he'd be fun to guest okay
but i felt threatened by it
you did so then i was just like what
about me but you're always welcome on
the show this is like your third time on
the show i
you're always welcome now i i used to be
one of your favorites on tiger belly i
haven't been on tiger bell in years
i know i'm not as famous as a lot of the
people you get on there that's crazy to
think that is it crazy it's not the
truth is it insecure it's not even the
truth
because i remember auditioning for a
smallville
and not even getting anywhere near who
did you audition for in small villages
old lady i don't know what a part was
but it was an old white lady
that was casting it oh you auditioned
for an old wife no it's like wow diverse
but my point is is that and then when
the show came out
i was a kid then but when the show came
out i was like oh these are real stars
that's all
that listen
you have god you're the hawk you call
ryan
it's the eagles what
ryan how do you feel about being known
as eagle face to bobby like it's nice to
be remembered
thank you yeah that's the first thing he
said he goes i do remember he called me
eagle face last time yeah it's just the
profile's nice
back to the uh talk about guests and
stuff sorry because i i watched an
interview with you and you with who it
was with just you and george and kalila
from tiger belly okay and it was a clip
where you talked about how you do ask
guests to come on the show
and you do text them but you hate the
rejection of them not answering you like
ronda rousey you text her to say i love
you on my podcast and she never
responded yeah i got her
the big one for me now is ike baron
holtz
i don't know who that is who is that uh
the comedy guy he was on
mindy project okay yeah you asked him
well i worked with ike for six years on
mad tv
right and him and i
traveled together and we were besties
very close
and then when matt got canceled you know
he had a pretty good really good career
you know really good career
and um i've asked him maybe four times
in my life
and every time it's some excuse it's
just fine i believe the excuses but i
can no longer ask again does he do other
podcasts no but that's not the point
jordan peele who was i was on mad tv
with yeah he did it he did it and he
this is after get out
so i mind you he was really busy
you know and he still did it right and i
you know i i understand that i love ike
and i'll or i'll forever love him from
the bottom of my heart
but um
i wouldn't save him if
a snake bit him
you wouldn't suck that vanilla i don't
think i would right at this point until
he does it
i
i embarrass myself quite frequently i
ask a lot of guests i need guests every
week to be on the show and you want
people to uh watch the show listen
follow
and so i have to go after them because i
don't really have anybody that helps me
for the most part
and so i get dealt with rejection
constantly
but you when you do land though you get
good ones you get you get guests i can't
get all right i could help you get them
i don't want them i want jordan peele
no
he wouldn't do it no why not
i can get you a chipolly shore
let's start there he lives in vegas i
asked him i know i know i know he does
but when he's in town next you'll see
what happens so what is this rejection
you don't like being rejected by your
friends especially when you reach out to
them
i think the problem is um they
a lot of my friends are
have acting careers
and it's not acting right so it's like
they don't also they're not privy to
the kind of audience that i have and um
it would be a positive thing for their
life i think if they did it
um so they think that it's um
also i have to also say that i've
changed
so it's like people that i met back 25
years ago 20 years ago think that i'm
going to like make them eat my pubes or
something
right because they think that i'm that
that the bobby lady yeah and it's like
no i i
i've changed
like i'm not as wild
and you're still wild
yeah but i'm pretty tame though i saw an
interview on q13 seattle where you're
about to do a show at the parlor and the
interview you just pretty much kept
moving to him as close as possible
sitting on his lap you kissed him
and uh
unless that was 20 years ago i don't
think it was
probably 10 years ago and and also um
i have to say i don't remember that okay
it is something that i probably would do
right but
you have to understand those morning
shows are so god have you you've done
them oh yeah they're still gonna have to
give them something that i have to do
something
to make it weird
and to to make it awkward
because i don't i'm not in there i'm not
like some of these comics like carlos
mancia or whatever that have just choke
choke choke choking do his bits stolen
joke joke jokes
that's a funny joke no thanks um
but anyway let's move on you don't want
to talk about that i don't
i want i do want to talk about
um how i've changed though
and i think tell me if it's because i'm
almost 50. yeah you're turning 50 next
year no in a couple weeks okay
are you having a party
i was gonna have one right but um i know
that you had a birthday dinner didn't
invite me but my point is is that um i
had 15 people come over and you you're
too busy for me you're true
you're famous now if you threw out a
line that would have been suffice
you would come
if you threw out a line who knows i will
always throw out a line for now and i
didn't want to bother you
i don't think that's what it was i don't
think that i was i think you would have
had a boring time you wouldn't know a
lot of people and you feel uncomfortable
and i saved you well i know you're a
board game kind of like let's do
charades kind of guy i've been to your
parties well
we can't have those parties nowadays i
know but you're one of those guys let's
get together and play
um
i don't know anything let me think of a
make up of a game you were thinking risk
karma johnsy or whatever chansey we put
the blocks on the thing and then we try
to pull it i don't know what it is but
my point is is that you're that type of
guy it's it's like old-timey 1970s jim
henson
party moriarty moriarty party
so you don't enjoy me i mean look at
that
yeah there's masks and things that's
what kind of mask is that that's from
smallville i wore that in an episode but
is that not a jim henson kind of a thing
i mean there's some jim henson puppets
up there yeah yeah yeah it's weird
is it weird
it is maybe because you know i
maybe it's a distraction the more
distractions i have in the house the
less i have to deal with me
by the way did i do it i told you i miss
you i miss you do you know i was i
hadn't i've had anxiety what's your
problem
you have a vibe i have a vibe do you
like his vibe
no it's like almost like he's nervous or
something he's not nervous i'm nervous
everything's fine
okay
no he's like fidgeting and you know he's
writing what is he writing he's writing
notes he's saying cut this this is
boring yeah all of this you're going to
call it no this is great yeah so you're
turning 50.
so you're not going to have a party
you're not going to do anything i was
going to have a big shindig i was going
to get a restaurant i was going to
invite as as many people as i could but
then delta happened delta variance yeah
and it's just like you know
we're still in it
there was many thoughts that i had like
because i got facts and all that stuff
that i was like oh this is the new age
you know this is and it's like no we're
still in it it's terrible so can't you
get some friends together like me
no i i don't i can't do it because of um
because of kalila
what do you mean you can't do it because
of your wife
i didn't realize you're married
i'm not married it says online you were
married i know you're married i know
you do know that's good you know that do
you think we're married i think you're
married i think you got married in 2016.
and you really didn't tell people
we are married yeah
inside of you is brought to you by sonos
i freaking i've talked about this i love
sonos guys i've had sonos before they
were a sponsor i've had sonus in my
house
for over 15 years i love sonos i like to
listen to a different song in each room
of the house i could put it on party
mode and listen to the whole house full
of music it's just so easy the sound is
terrific they've got this new speaker
sonos rome look at this guys look how
tiny this is it weighs almost nothing
and you could just
like the title says rome you could have
it anywhere in the house you could just
bring it with you sonus rome is the
ultra portable smart speaker that allows
you to bring the sonos experience
everywhere you go rome weighs less than
a pound its premium durable design makes
it perfect for the home and for on the
go when you're home
rome connects to your wi-fi network and
the rest of your sonos system and then
automatically pairs with your phone on
bluetooth when you're on the go for a
seamless experience using automatic true
play tuning roam smartly adapts to your
surroundings and whatever you're
listening to and creates sound that's
astonishingly detailed and perfectly
balanced
that is correct ryan control rome using
the app apple airplay 2 or your voice
with amazon alexa or google assistant
with sonos you could start with one
speaker and expand your system over time
like i have i have one in every room as
i've talked about all sonos speakers
connect over wi-fi so you can group
speakers in different rooms and play
music throughout your home you are not
going to regret this you have to check
out the new sonos rome uh i love sonos
thank you sonos for being a sponsor and
you guys need to check it out because
it's an amazing amazing device inside of
you is brought to you by my good friends
at
better help online therapy this is
working i don't know how many people
have come up to me ryan at conventions
saying i tried better help it's really
saving my life it's really helping me
one of those people is helping is ryan
it's helping me it's a helpful service
and you guys in the name help help
better help better help and you did you
get a new therapist uh i did um yeah
just uh just recently right because uh
ryan had a therapist and so he wanted
another therapist and so that's what
happened it's so easy better help online
therapy really has done a great job and
i really appreciate having them on the
response as a sponsor uh
they're just so fitting that's what we
do here we talk about a lot of things
depression anxiety look whether you're
struggling with grief relationships or
stress or you're having trouble sleeping
or meeting goals online therapy
might be for you better help us secure
online therapy that offers video phone
and even live chat sessions with a
licensed professional therapist better
help will assess your needs and match
you with your own accredited therapist
you can start communicating in under 48
hours and you don't have to sit in an
uncomfortable waiting room
therapists have a broad range of
expertise which may not be available in
your area the service is available for
clients worldwide you can log into your
account anytime and send a message to
your therapist you'll get timely and
thoughtful responses plus you can
schedule weekly video or phone sessions
it's really
amazing and easy and better help is
committed to facilitating great
therapeutic matches so they make it easy
and free to change therapists if you
need like ryan it's also more affordable
than traditional offline therapy and
financial aid is available i'm telling
you offline therapy is so much more
expensive coming from someone who has
gone through a lot of therapy i'm
telling you this is the way to go it's
easy visit
betterhelp.com
inside and join the over 2 million
people who have taken charge of their
mental health with the help of an
experienced professional inside of you
is sponsored by betterhelp and our
listeners get 10 off their first month
of online therapy at betterhelp.com
slash inside that's better help
b-e-t-t-e-r-h-e-l-p
dot com slash inside better help online
therapy try it folks inside of you is
brought to you by geico how do you
banish high rates on car insurance it's
easy you switch to geico during
geicoween
i love making that sound by the way you
like that let me do it again do it again
[Laughter]
yeah whatever
october is geico's favorite time of year
and geico has been working even harder
to cast out high rates on car insurance
and craft just the right coverage for
you and your family but here's the thing
you may not know about geico ryan they
could also help you uncover more savings
when you bundle the other things parked
in your driveway like your beloved
motorcycle boat or even home away from
home your rv geico could even help you
save on homeowners and renters insurance
so visit geico.com today and you'll see
firsthand that switching your insurance
coverage doesn't have to be scary the
only thing that will haunt your
nightmares is seeing just how much you
could have saved if you had switched
sooner
geico
15 minutes could save you 15 or more on
car insurance
happy guy co-ween
[Music]
anyway um let's talk about us
you talk about awesome listen let's talk
about us i i i i think i'm in a point
right now that i want to talk about
awesome okay fine
it's my interview you know uh i i've
been getting i've been getting some
anxiety lately and my thing is that i
get overwhelmed by everything now things
that i didn't normally get overwhelmed
with so every little thing
gets me overwhelmed do you deal with
this stuff do you deal with are you
overwhelmed by things because it seems
like you used to be
now the new bobby you've got so many new
so much new [ __ ] you're doing so many
new shows i mean i can name the [ __ ]
shows there's reservation dogs uh what's
this one episode one episode but what's
the you have a development deal at cbs
it's almost over in two weeks
okay and you something you know there's
something else you did you did a movie
with uh eli roth uh the director
right with cate blanchett that comes out
next summer i mean you got a lot of
things going on here i have two i have
two lines let's let's look at things in
perspective you don't have two lines you
they flew you overseas
i know but because of covet though
this is what it would have been like if
that movie was shot in la right
shoot two days thank you
and then you never see anybody again
right right but the but with because of
covid i was flown to hungary and because
of their laws and and restrictions right
the production was like basically is you
have to stay here
and i go well when am i shooting they're
like you're shooting um
this date and then you're not gonna
shoot for another three and a half weeks
that's your next scene
so it's like what do i do oh you get to
stay in the hotel
so i spent
about close to a month
doing nothing
in a in a hotel
in hungary you had to be going out of
your mind
well i know the problem there's there's
there's an actress named janina gavin
carr
who
in the movie she's like the my boss
pretty much so she kind of had the same
days off as me
she hung out with her so i hang out with
her and then like
at the four seasons there
right there you know there's like five
or six productions
so there it was fun to go to like the
restaurant and to see all the stars
because you would see like oscar isaac
walk by you know with this plate of his
omelette
you know i mean or you would see john
kranzinski or all these people did you
talk to any of these people no but i
would like do like a little smirk
and look and they would lock eyes and
that would go back into my like bagel
did they recognize you at all no nobody
recognize you no it's funny because even
in this movie i had to like kind of tell
people what i did
like you know i'm in the movie like
there was a couple of lunches where
well you know you know jamie lee curtis
right i've heard of her god but you know
her
yes i don't know her personally yeah
well she
is a mensch
you love her well i didn't know it i
would but like so the first day i went
there
because you have to imagine like you
know kevin hart jack black all these
people are in it right
this movie i have two scenes no one's
gonna give a [ __ ] about my character
right so when i was flying
too hungry i'm like i knew that i had a
month off so in my head i'm like you're
just gonna be by yourself i don't know
anybody
no one's gonna want to hang out with you
right so you're already i brought my
playstation
i'll just play 15 hours of war zone a
day whatever
so when i went into my hotel room
beautiful hotel room
there was a letter
on my bed
and it was written by jamie lee curtis
she goes welcome to the show
here's my number or whatever let's hang
out
so the next day she she texts me she
goes downstairs noon i mean yeah noon
brunch or whatever
so it went down there and she's in the
movie she's in the movie obviously so
i'm there with her
i met penn gillette from penn teller
right janina went
and then
a week later i shot a scene and then a
week later i had another lunch with cate
blanchett wait alone no with a bunch of
people right it was like these are two
three-hour lunches because it was on a
saturday whatever
and they were fun
you had fun i think i'd be overwhelmed
no in the beginning it's not but then
you realize that like um
we're all they were you have to imagine
that all these stars had come out of
this pandemic
for many of them this is their first job
back
and so many of them they've been in you
know locked up for over a year so
they're excited so they're kind of like
they want to like bond and you know even
though like i'm pretty much in like an
open micro
you know what i mean like this is newbie
some guy had really you know i've done a
line here or two and things but
but they treated me like i was part of
the part of the group yeah
so it felt cool now it was magical
actually who are you still for could you
text right now jamie lee curtis i do
have her number but i would never tell
why don't you text her right now no no
no no
no no no no no i will not why don't you
just say hey i just thought i'd say hi
great working with you i miss you no
because i don't want to be intrusive
like i have so many numbers in my phone
you probably have these too but you can
get around the podcast
well see here's my plan though
my plan is to do it when the movie's
about to come out
and then ask them all i will ask them
all then you have cate blanchett's
number no
she was one i don't have how is she in
person though
well she just i don't want to get
emotional but i don't want to get
emotional get emotional but it's like
she's
not only funny
but she's
so sweet like
there was one moment where i was like
somebody had said a joke
and everyone was kind of laughing at the
table and she was literally right here
right right and she goes the people are
like so imagine she goes
and she did this that's me right she
goes
grabbed your shoulder and rubbed it and
rubbed it like that and i go ha ha i go
no i didn't do that but i went and you
know i was like
cool you know what i mean cate blanchett
touched you yeah part of the game right
and then like um
but it was funny then like other people
would come to the production that like
were shooting later so i i got to hang
out with gina gershon
and she's a sw you know i mean one night
we were at dinner and she goes i'm just
gonna get drunk and so i just sat there
with with her and this other actor named
ben davis and they just started doing
shots of this weird like hungarian
beverage you know
you know i don't drink right right but
for hours
yapping it up and then josh hartnell was
on the next table in this restaurant and
they came to the table so it was a whole
magic and then you come back to l.a and
you're like i'm a podcaster
you mean like you know me i'm like you
know that's what i am no you're not yeah
i am why do you think that you've done
tons of movies you've done tv shows
we did a good one
is it but listen
still the funniest line you know the
funniest line
was when miguel nunez
in the movie yeah i was kidding and i
said i'm never doing another jamie
kennedy movie and he says he doesn't
[ __ ] jamie can't i never do
another jamie kennedy
that was the best line so when you're
with cate blanchett and all these people
in europe yeah in hungary hungry yeah
do you feel like bobby lee can you be
yourself and be that different kind of
funny quirky guy or are you just quiet
and you're not yourself you end up
hiding certain elements of your i'm
going to tell you a story that happened
then all right
and this is why i changed my behavior
because so i forgot to tell you so jamie
the first lunch we had right there's
another actor named cheyenne jackson
that's also in the movie right very
talented guy
handsome can dancing do it all right so
jamie goes
let's go but let's walk to the river
so this is where
i threw in my personality and it
backfired oh boy so i go so we were
walking along this naked no oh okay
worse okay so there's like eight of us
and along this river
along the side are these bronze
shoes
stuck on the you know edge part of the
there's a
hood rose of it right and i guess back
during the holocaust oh god yeah the
nazis came in and they just lined up
jewish people
and they shot killed them and threw them
into the river it's not going to a good
place
already
right
so um cheyenne jackson goes
she he sees little shoes
right and everyone kind of
gathers around
the little shoes
and he goes oh my god
a little boy
and people are like emotional
so i go
it could have been a [ __ ]
nobody laughed no not
it worse
they all collectively turned around
and walked away
so i'm now just with by the shoes you're
awesome
my head's down like it's the first day
it's the first [ __ ] day dude
so i'm not my head is down looking at
the shoes and just in my head you know
you go through the thing
like dude why did you do that
this is not a bunch of comedians you
mean this is your gut is wrong
you cannot do that again right so the
whole trip there were so many instances
where i wanted to [ __ ] throw out a
banger
right and i just
my filter went no
stop
you know so after that you didn't do
anything so i had to hide
an aspect of my [ __ ] personality
did you ever think of saying sorry about
the [ __ ] no i never even brought it up
i pretended as if it never happened
oh god i know it was terrible and then
in fact i think cheyenne jackson
right
i think he
he was very nice right
but i could tell that maybe it was in my
own head but like because i said that
joke he couldn't get that too close to
me
but then like when i first when he was
there in my first scene and i did well
then after that
it kind of
resolved itself right who did you act
with
did you act with cate blanchett no no i
had one scene with her but it was it was
almost i get
i get um
tazed
right right and then i fall on my back
and then
kate blanchett and kevin hart have a
scene
over my body and you have to just lie
there for her and i'm laying there so i
guess that's a scene sure yeah yeah
you're the tased guy i'm the tails guy
did were you astonished by kate's acting
amazed
i'm just amazed by like just sitting
there like there was one scene where um
gina gershon had a big monologue kind of
thing to say and just and i'm reverse i
have no line but i'm in the scene
and i'm just dancing in there and
watching
it you know because it's like
you know the shows that i do which i i
love the shows i do i've done i've been
on sitcoms and i've been on um i mean
sometimes i do magnum pi some of these
shows
and it's like the energy
and the i think
the the level is completely different
you know
it's like you know when you do tv and
you know this is you feel like there's a
sense of urgency because it's like they
have yeah they have to move on you know
i mean it's like
you do a couple takes like that's fine
let's just move on you know even though
like i want a different another tag
but with with you know films as you know
as well is is that they let things
breathe there's more time a lot more
shooting there's more shooting more
angles more
you know there's more discussions about
the scene whereas like the director will
go
yeah just the tone and the energy i
think you know i mean probably just slow
down whatever it might be you know i
mean it's like a different vibe you know
so it's like
you just want to
you just want to learn how to do all of
it i guess did you feel like you wanted
to be go ahead take a drink of your red
bull
you can do that you've eyed it how many
red bulls is that for you today just
every
night in my head i hear
it could have been a [ __ ]
like every night i go to bed and i just
that just kind of rings in my head maybe
one day it echoes it could have been a
[ __ ] it could have been a magic
mention it could be a rap song yeah yeah
yeah yeah yeah i've been a rap song yeah
and first of all you did not even say
you're not even supposed to i should
have said a little person cause you're
not allowed to even say [ __ ] anymore i
was gonna say when you're on a set with
these folks
do you still get because i know you used
to be where you're always thinking of
failing you're always thinking of like
[ __ ] i'm gonna get fired i'm gonna get
this they're gonna hate me do you not do
that anymore do you say specifically
yeah do you think you're more confident
now with just your acting and your
ability
or do you get overwhelmed no no no it's
different it's how is it different
and what did you do to make it different
i i've never wanted to talk about this
but um
i guess i will
it's
it's podcasting
so you know before when i would be in
things like
years ago i did a show called animal
practice i didn't have a podcast and and
at the time my standup i wasn't making a
lot of money on the road so everything
relied on you know let's i have to
become a serious regular it's gotta run
for seven years so then i can make you
know my forever money right
but now it's like
acting is
not
the forefront of the thing it's like
i um
if i get five
fine
right you really think that no but also
secondly
no not but that that's there right but
there's a second element to it which is
also
i've done so many
things i came to a realization that i've
done
10 movies i've been a series regular on
three shows but i've done six pilots
right i've done
so many guest stars right i've done on
every
and it's like i understand how it all
works and i also understand that i'm
good
wow
that's an accomplishment like there's i
i can sincerely say that
there's no one that can do it the way i
do it
right and i know that i
can
kill it in a different way than another
actor can
none that it's better or worse
i just know that when like when because
i mean when eli hired me eli it was it
wasn't because i mean i auditioned but
eli was like no i saw you on something
else
and that sprung up
you know i mean that bobby would be
perfect for this role right
so it's like oh if he saw me in
something else that means that
he thought it was good
right so then you know you kind of think
you know and the first scene was with
kevin hart and i remember it was one of
those scenes where
they had these gigantic green screens
you're in the desert right and there's
like these machines it's a big sci-fi
movie
right there's like
hundreds of extras with guns and you
know what i mean
and so it's like it's so many extras
what's it called the movie's called
borderlands is based on a video game
so i remember walking from the tent to
this thing and i just remember repeat
because i saw rose and amma eunice do
this
she said um
i'm the best i'm the best i'm the best
and
when she right before her she delivered
the lines no rose number uses a fighter
okay
and i just said to myself
i'm the best i'm the best i'm the best
you're gonna kill it you're gonna kill
it you're gonna kill like this mantra
positive reinforcement oh yeah
and when i walked on set i killed it
like i i like
eli is like
we don't even have to do no let's do
another one for fun
just like that yeah yeah so it's like
and it was like i you know i had like 10
lines in this thing i had to walk around
and grab things and you know
i tied up kevin hart you know i mean so
i'm like kind of torturing him i guess
and i'm just kind of like doing this
little tiny
speech right not huge i'm not going to
win many awards but it's just like i
know i had to do it and i did it so you
think because of the podcast success and
the millions of dollars you're making no
it's not the money it's what it is is um
when i go on the road
and i see tiger belly fans
or like because i'm in new york shooting
something right now too
and i'm i and i i'm i'm on the street in
brooklyn right on my day off and people
coming up to me going
it's a different thing than
mad tv it's like they know me
you know they'll walk up and they'll go
they'll sit down and we'll talk
and it's just a different
is it that you maybe you feel like you
belong is what you're saying like like
you're like no i feel like i have a
family
i have a family of people
don't get me wrong i mean obviously i i
go online and i know all the hate
there are people that really hate me
really oh yeah like they can't have
you know i mean they think that i'm
gross or whatever it might be right but
you read all that oh yeah
not
not i try not to but sometimes
you know you want to read um
you try to fish for something a
compliment do you fight back no you
don't respond no i bet you did in the
past no never you never once said [ __ ]
you you know don't watch if you don't
like me
no
because
what does it matter
you know mitzi once told me
mitzi so they know is it shore mitzi
shore who ran into me and cleveland me
and the guy named freddie soda we used
to drive her around
back in the 90s
and she she has a plaque on her
she used to have a plaque on her desk
that said
it is it is a sin to support mediocrity
so we talked about that
and she goes um
you can't walk up to somebody that
doesn't have talent and say that they
have talent
that's the worst thing you can do
and she goes um
here's another word of advice she goes
do you know what makes a true star
and i go what because i was a kid
and she goes
half the people have to love you
but simultaneously
the other half have to hate you
just as long as they're talking baby
wow and that sunk the hell in isn't it
right
so the negative stuff
it's still good
it's still real good
how many people listen to tiger belly i
don't know
you should know that i'm sure
i'm gonna be honest with you
it's okay you could put the glasses on
jason voorhees
don't let me forget these okay
i have to be honest with you okay you're
going in close i know you're still good
you still got me yeah
number one
go [ __ ] yourself okay i'm kidding i
don't know that wasn't even the thing
and number two eagle that was the land
okay so number one right
i literally don't know how much money
any of my i have two podcasts bad
friends generate generate right you
don't have any idea how much they
generate ask andrew i don't have to be a
businessman no i don't have nothing i
don't know any of it
i don't know any of it
does kalila she does okay number two
i don't know how any of it works
i don't know how to turn it on i don't
know how it gets on the thing i don't
know that sounds like me yeah i don't
know how how any of it works right i
don't know who how they get sponsors i
don't know how you make merchandise i
don't know what it generates i don't
know any of the details
this is what i do now
is
i'll be upstairs and collider will be
like all right we're ready
i'll go down i'll put these things on
i'll do it and i walk and i'll do some
ads and then i'll walk back upstairs
with andrew he's there 30 minutes before
me
i show up everything's on and i just
valentino andrew santune i do it and i
leave and then what happens is i told
him what he does is he'll send the money
to my accountant
right and my accountant
oversees it all
and i don't i don't talk to i haven't i
literally haven't talked to my account
in a year
do you think this is good yeah
why is it good
as someone who's making money who came
from poverty who came from sleeping on
paulie shore's couch i know my point
i'll
because it's like
if i live in a world where everyone's
embezzling
and people are stealing from me
and all that stuff
i already know just i won't be able to
function and it's like it makes it will
create all this unhappiness
right so there's a degree of trust that
goes on right so
my manager who i've been around for
that
has been my manager for 25 years
she got me her and my accountant are
very close
right
they've known each other since the 70s
or whatever
so it's like you know
i just there's a level of trust there
you know do you think it helps you being
that you're just focusing on what you're
doing and not worrying about the money
and the business and the technical [ __ ]
you think that is what helps you
yeah but it's also
i know when there's danger so it's like
years ago before tiger belly i had my
same accountant
and there was one point where i was
spending so much money on clash of clans
what clash of clans i don't know what
that is you know teddy's ryan yeah phone
game it's a phone game okay i had spent
ten thousand dollars
buying troops for cat clashing clans
i don't play that's why i might stop
playing it okay good but in like two
months i racked up ten thousand i wanted
to build the fortress
and you have to pay you know i mean
online right so it's like ten thousand
dollars right and then my accountant go
called me and goes whatever that is
clash of clans you delete it right now
you don't have the money
you're you're running out of money we
can't pay this this and this and this
there was a time where i could how many
years ago was this this is eight years
ago right he's like or whenever clash of
clans seven years ago and he's like
done it's over no more cash so i deleted
it
right so it's like i know when there's
danger
clash
of what clans
you spent ten thousand dollars on a
phone app yeah
inside of you is brought to you by monk
pack healthy snacks have a bad
reputation and let's be honest
most don't taste very good
they don't fill you up and they
certainly don't satisfy your cravings
this episode is sponsored by monk pack
who makes snacks that taste like our
favorite sugary treats but with one gram
of sugar or less
monk pack keto granola bars contain just
one gram of sugar two to three grams of
net carbs and they're only 140 calories
they're gluten free grain free
plant-based and non-gmo with no soy
trans fat sugar alcohols or
high-intensity sweeteners while they're
great for anyone following a keto
lifestyle you absolutely do not have to
be keto to love these they are the
perfect snack for anyone who is trying
to eat better or cut back on sugar and
carbs without sacrificing taste i love
granola i love the monk pack granola uh
it's delicious it's what i'm uh into and
uh great taste monk pack keto granola
bars have a soft and chewy texture and
come in delicious flavors like coconut
cocoa chip peanut butter and blueberry
almond vanilla you know hey these these
are great for when you're on the go you
know we want to eat healthier everyone's
always talking about eating healthier
doing things that are have less calories
a little more nutritional value
this is good for me i love granola
and uh it's it's quick and easy and when
you're on the go i'm i'm always running
out of the house i just grab something
and go i don't have to make a meal i
don't have to go fast food
so it's really saved me they're perfect
for a quick breakfast a snack between
zoom calls or a guilt-free dessert they
taste incredible and you can't beat the
low sugar nutrition they provide and by
shopping online you can avoid another
trip to the grocery store by getting
monk pack delivered right to your door
try it for yourself and see and we have
a special deal for our listeners get 20
off your first purchase of any monk pack
product by visiting monkpack.com
and entering our code iou at checkout
and monkpack is so confident in their
product it's backed with a 100
satisfaction guarantee if you don't like
it for any reason they'll exchange the
product or refund your money whichever
you prefer so to get started folks just
go to monk pack
m-u-n-k-p-a-c-k.com and select any
product then enter the code iou at
checkout to save 20 percent off your
purchase monk pack delicious nutritious
food you can count on and we thank them
for sponsoring the podcast inside he was
brought to you by m1 finance look up in
the sky it's the finance
super app
invest with powerful tools and unmatched
automation borrow with some of the
lowest rates or spend your hard-earned
cash from their secure digital checking
account m1 finance does it all all with
a few taps in their sleek modern app
it's no wonder money investopedia and
yahoo finance are raving about this app
or that hundreds of thousands of
investors have trusted over five billion
dollars in assets on the platform
they say you shouldn't always go with
the flow but this tidal wave of cash and
savvy financiers might be on to
something plus get a thirty dollar bonus
to your m1 invest account when you get
approved and fund it with one thousand
dollars within your first 14 days
go to
m1finance.com
inside of you to get started that's m
as in michael the number one
finance.com
m1finance.com investing involves risk
including the risk of loss borrowing on
margin can add to these risks rates may
vary terms and conditions apply
hey when you're doing bad friends with
andrew santino do you guys ever start
doing it and go this sucks let's redo it
last sunday we did one for an hour and a
half
and we at the end of somebody said
i think i said
at the end i go yeah this is honorable
and he goes what he's on a terrible he
goes i know
i go what's wrong he's like i'm tired
i'm tired too we're not connecting
all that stuff that hour and a half was
a waste
he goes what do you want to do
let's meet tomorrow so monday we met
it was better
not i they said it was better i didn't
think it was better but um
it happens all the time andrew and i
have podcasts that we can never air or
or we will
no longer have careers
you have an episode we have one episode
that's in a vault
where we went you know because we had
one of those days where it was like it's
not connecting i go why don't we just
experiment and let's just just do one
where
we can say whatever we want just
anything just anything to provoke so we
did one where we could say anything
right
racist things you know sexual things
and things that
will get us canceled
and we had
the best podcast we could ever do
because it was just raw it was
so funny where i would have to grab the
side my side and fall on the ground
and go stop stop stop we got to stop i'm
going to die laughing
like it was so aren't you afraid that
somebody will get that merit
how
it's in a vault like i said you took the
tapes or the disc yeah yeah yeah yeah
but it's it's like um
it was so freeing
you know i wish in in many ways the
world was like that
it's kind of a shame that you can't kind
of say what you want i mean you know you
got to be a little sensitive but
nowadays it's like uh you know
i'm not going to mention any names
because then i'll get lambasted but like
you know one guy said something 10 years
ago and he just lost his job
that's like people don't evolve anymore
people say stupid [ __ ] if you heard half
the [ __ ] i say
i just don't know if we're gonna ever i
think it's gonna get worse and worse or
it will get i don't i don't know
yeah man
i mean it's here i mean i'll throw my
two cents in it's like um
i've said a lot of things
i mean first of all i've done thousands
of hours
i don't even i can't even calculate it
over the last 20 years of radio shows
and
podcasts and all the things i've said
and it's like
it got to the point
where i've realized that pretty much
everything i'm saying
i'm making up right maybe there's like a
little kernel of truth to it
but it's like embellishment how to
extend it you know i mean how do i make
it exciting and um
i would there's a bunch of [ __ ] that i
would hear from other friends and make
it my own story
and there's just so many instances that
are like that that it's like um
it's you just don't say the right thing
all the time
it's not even that it's just like i just
feel like
anything said in this domain
like in terms of radio or podcast right
especially when it's a comedy podcast
and you're a comedian right that it
should like shane gillis
you know that guy that said
ra asian stuff like he's gonna do my
podcast in a week or whatever he got
fired from snl that's the most atrocious
thing i've ever heard in my [ __ ] life
what did he say he says janker i don't
know what he might have said right but
you know here's a guy an actor who got
cast in snl and then 10 years ago i
don't know how long ago was but he said
some asian slur right on a podcast and
he gets fired from snl is
the most it's so atrocious
right that they would do that
because
podcasting
and the things that we say here it's
sacred and it's like entertainment if
you don't like it don't listen to it
it's fine i don't there's so many people
that don't like me but there's a lot of
people that do it it's fine i get it
right but it's like you know
if you you know uh uh somebody said on a
bad friend's comment
um
yeah this show's lost it like you guys
used to be so much funnier it's like
well then listen to something else right
you know i mean it's like i you know we
talk so long and not all of them are
going to be bangers man but don't you
think that doing a podcast you can say
whatever you want because they can't but
you can they can't cancel your podcast
who can cancel your podcast but the
problem is is is that when you say
certain things on podcasts
that aren't true
and that are strictly for comedy you can
lose your job
not podcasting but you can lose
corporate jobs right and you can lose
some friends you know i mean you can
lose there's certain things that you can
lose that i've seen
happen
right yeah um
then that's all you're gonna say about
that
i mean there's really not much to say
about it it's like you know
i've said it a thousand times now you
know something happened
it didn't bother me but i was like you
you your dad passed away and you came on
the show and you were very emotional and
uh you know i i love how vulnerable you
were it was awesome i appreciate it but
you also said i couldn't talk about that
you went off the wagon but then you said
it on theo on shelf so first i was a
little upset that oh
probably at the time
probably at the time i didn't come out
well then i decided in a day or two
afterwards that i would
you know people change their minds and
people things shift don't take it
personally i i don't yeah so i did
realize i did i did why i did i think
you did i didn't i think you [ __ ] did
no i just said i think you're like a
little baby no the first thing that came
to me was yeah theo's got a way bigger
show it makes more sense
that's what came to me
what you what ding dong
you [ __ ] idiot
let me just say this okay
you and i are both in recovery and we
both struggle with addiction or don't
you think that that could be it you
[ __ ] idiot it is it is you're not
taking things so you're a millionaire
let me ask you something yeah i just
don't like the way you stuck that in
there i apologize yeah i just threw it
in there i didn't really mean anything
about your glasses back on this is
ridiculous no no keep them off you're
more honest when you're i like when
you're angry
when you went off the wagon when you
went to rehab oh my god what the [ __ ]
man how hard was that
that's what i just heard there
well oh so you talked about it on this
video okay what
what do you want to know pal i want to
know how difficult it was for you to
admit it to actually go
and what you learned and how you got
back on the way it wasn't rehab [ __ ]
up hard it wasn't no [ __ ] hard listen
i thought it was it wasn't like [ __ ] box
hey listeners yeah when he says [ __ ]
tart and all these things it's it's
friendship it's pure french you don't
need to think that he's being vulgar i'm
not gonna angry i'm just saying that i'm
i i feel like if you were larry king i
wouldn't be talking to you like this i
thought we had a friend where if
i'm not offended i think some people
might be offended at how you're talking
to me no i don't think they would i
don't think it was i don't know but my
point
i went to a place
to deal with my trauma
okay
in arizona yes it was a place that other
people that i knew that i respected went
through right and my father was so
violent growing up right that i
absorbed all that
suffering and all that shock and trauma
right into my body
it was pinned up there all these years
you know and it's like i needed to a way
to deal with it and release it and
that's by doing that i got sober
again
right but it wasn't i didn't go to the
place to get sober in fact
when i was flying there klyla flew there
with me to arizona and i looked at her
and i said
you know i'm not gonna get sober right
she's like i know
and i go
how do you feel about that
and she goes
it sucks
and i go
i'm sorry
but by going to that place
i got sober
because you released all this other [ __ ]
yeah i did emdr i did that
the mdr i did it
i had a breakthrough
did you have a breakthrough
he's doing the bobby lee stare eagle
face help me out
it's just let me finish yeah i'm sorry
first time i've interrupted you today
i've learned i've become a better
podcaster i did that
i just was trying to like i love you i
know go ahead i did that for comedy
purposes that was good i liked it thank
you um
so you you you use it does work it does
work yeah
so um i did emdr on this one incident
right which seemed to like do a lot for
me which is um
[Music]
when i was like
eight or nine years old maybe younger
um
i remember my mother waking me up we
were leaving minnesota
and
she turned the lights on in the room but
my brother steve and i slept in the same
room
and um
she was
crying and she opened her mouth
and all i could see was blood
yeah are you hard no i'm upset
i had to take a deep breath oh i thought
you were getting an erection no could
you imagine yes i read a run go on
please
continue
and so um
[Music]
jesus
my mom goes
in korean
help me with the door
to my brother and we're kids
and she closes the door and i can see
like
you don't want to remind me of his
shining
remember when he cracks open the little
crack in the door and he sticks his head
through here's johnny here's johnny
that's what i felt like
so we're just sitting there my mom and i
right and just the
door being right
and we just knew that it was gonna be
bad
when my dad walked in
right it was gonna be bad
violence
and then um he gets in and that's where
my memory stops i don't know what
happened
but i remember the fear
of being by that door
with my brother and my mom trying to get
my dad to not come in because he was
going through a drunken rage
right
and um
we did emdr on that specific um
experience
and it was um
it relieved it it kind of like
it kind of
like i know it happened but the feeling
in my body when i think about it is gone
you know yeah
and um they say that when you leave
trauma in your body
and it's not dealt with
that it could turn into diseases
and it affects you physically and i
and i know this from experience because
the reason why i was in the [ __ ]
place in the first place was when my dad
died
for a month
i didn't eat or sleep for a whole month
i didn't know why every time i i went on
the road i was in portland and i was
with two openers chelsea
skidmore and stephen randolph her
husband
and we were at a sushi restaurant and i
hadn't eaten days and i'm gonna try to
eat i took a bite of some sushi and i
vomited it right and i didn't know what
the [ __ ] was going on i'm like my dad
dies and now i can't eat or sleep
right
so then
i um my friend sosi
ran into me and so she said
you look like [ __ ] and i go
i know
and she was with kalala was there too
and she's like you should see my
therapist
so i went to a therapist so i haven't
eaten slept i'm smoking weed for 24
hours a day
right and i'm now in my therapist's
office
and we start talking about
my dad and growing up and
the violence that i grew up with
and the weirdest [ __ ] thing happened
i go all right well thanks for doing the
therapy when i got in the car
it was in the places in encino the the
therapy
from
encino to my house in um studio city
i went to three different restaurants
and i ate a meal
i could eat again
by just talking about just by talking
about my dad
and that experience therapy dude so in
my head i was like oh there's a
connection between
how i was raised
right and the experiences that i had to
my physical body now
right so then i decided to go away
to go to a trauma institute
a psycholo psychological institute to
deal with this stuff and i did emdr and
this and that and i got sober through it
and i came out
a different guy you know
and
that same therapist that she i still
every thursday
i have therapy with this woman every
thursday you meet oh yeah and do you
still talk about deep stuff or do you
think everything you've talked about is
sort of you no we still talk about the
past but we also talk about um
that's another reason why i can show up
on sets and stuff and i have a different
vibe about me you know it's like it's
funny it's like
years ago before like i remember being
like um on animal practice and the russo
brothers were my show runners you know
they're huge directors now
but i remember like you know being
around them
and not talking to them
like like it was almost they give you
notes and then it's like i go back to my
chair
and i just read my script and there's no
like
connection connection right right
but now it's like every job that i have
no matter what like i'm doing a small
part in sex in the city stop saying
small park just saying doing the part
three or four lines all right well
you're doing a part a part and um you're
right i should stop doing that and you
know
the show you know michael the showrunner
or if it's eli roth for the movie or if
it's like
i did this reservation dog sterling or
any of these jobs i have they're in my
cell phone and we're friends and we talk
and we goof around and my myself on set
wow and you know i mean and it's a
completely different
experience it's like they're my friends
producers like imagine pi the producer
of magnum pi jean
you're right it's one of my best friends
like we eat dinner and that wasn't like
you no
i would not even i don't i i would think
to myself they don't want to be bothered
right you're just a higher you know i
mean you're just
expendable or whatever but i it's like a
completely different vibe like you're
there for a reason you're worthy right
yeah i believe that i
belong there and i believe
that i'm just as good or better than
anyone else
that's a mix can i have your therapist
no
i'm not i'm not kidding
i'd like to
why not
all right why can't i just meet with her
i really i mean if she if you have such
a breakthrough because you are different
in many ways
that i that i'd love to meet
this woman i'm different in a lot of
ways yeah and it's like um
you know i've had a tough month i don't
want to get into it but um
a tough couple of months and um just
a lot of crying and a lot of like
confusion
and um but then so so i have great
things going on too but it's like
i don't know if if i wasn't in therapy
that i would be able to deal with all
the things that
are going on in my life the good and the
bad well what do you do to deal with
them because like listen we're getting
older you're going to be 50. i'm going
to be 50. like you know i i force myself
to try and work out a couple times a
week i try to what do you do
do you do any exercise no
stop you don't do any exercise man you
really don't whatever
during the people you're turning 50 if
things are starting to happen if i die i
died my point is that
during the if i die
but the pandemic i did like 40 yoga
sessions
okay that's a [ __ ] a lot a lot right
and then um i stopped doing them
did it help you it i loved it
can i have your yoga teacher she's great
kara from hawaii she's the best
i mean i she's my first one but like she
kalila goes to her
she's really great and um
so you're doing things you've done a lot
i'm doing a lot of things yeah but and
you're not overwhelmed
i feel great
you do have doesn't he seem different
than the last time yeah i mean except
when he gets a longer and yells at me no
i don't think you do you think that i
don't care though
okay i mean if you think that that's
great no i i do yeah tell me this story
really quick before you wrap up we're
done not done we're close why
i just i'm just starting going
well i want to hear this i started
getting going
why is it an hour huh well why did you
quit yoga first of all why did you stop
she went out of town and then i got
someone else no it's her she's the one
anyway ask me the question i just did
that's the question that you haven't
written down well no oh yeah no could
you imagine i knew what you were going
to say oh yeah yeah no you told the
story and i just thought it was really
funny go ahead
toby maguire leo dicaprio and wahlberg
were in a jacuzzi at uh toby just don't
go out stop stop stop
stop okay
it just made me laugh i understand i
understand that so
this is this is one of those uh stories
that i don't know if it exactly happened
the way i said it did right so you're
taking out of context you're
embellishing you're having fun with it
right so this is
basically it's true i know it this is
the real story okay okay
late at night i don't know what night it
was but my friend mike
called me and says i'm drunk
i'm on vine
okay
so when your friend's in a drunk drunk
and it's two in the morning your natural
response is
i'm [ __ ] sleeping like you know
what the [ __ ] like i don't we don't hang
out
like he's not like you if it was you i
wouldn't maybe you know no maybe maybe
and he go i go where are you i'm on vine
and this and this so i pick him up
this must have been 15 years ago
and i go where's your car
and he goes
i don't remember
so we're just kind of driving on vine
and then i go on like
beverly and we kind of just do a u-turn
back around you know
and then he goes oh yeah yeah yeah
i'll tell you
so he kind of goes this way this way so
we're now going up in the hills his car
was at toby maguire's house okay right
and
now this is where it this is where it
gets um
i don't know
which is
he comes in he goes back there he goes
wait here
he comes back and he goes
people are jacuzzi
i don't know
i think it was dicaprio but i don't know
for certain
maybe wahlberg i'm not for certain but
there were people
and toby maybe you're not certain i'm
not certain right and he goes do you
want to go
and it's like if it was regular people i
might have done it
because at the time i was single right
right
but like i think the reason why i didn't
was because there were stars there
and it's one of those things where it's
like
now knowing who i am now
100 would have done it
i would have been able to develop
relationships right
it would have been fun right
but now it's like um
no but go back
for the rest of the story
what
you said they're all interesting okay so
all right so the joke was
so
again
okay it's not true stop stop stop still
be finished okay let me finish i'm
trying okay
so
now when you go through an experience
like that right as a comic you go
how do i make it the story funnier
right so it's like oh
the bit is you know i mean what if they
were like the reason why i didn't go in
was my thinking was what if you know
they're gay
right
and they start you know what i mean
jacuzzi little gay orgy going on right
and now
being who i am at the level that i am
if spider-man's penis was in my face
right i would have to suck it is that
what you're saying
i would do it like in that scenario i
know where i was in the the totem pole
whatever
in hierarchy and i would have probably
done it that's why i didn't go in but
that's more of a joke than
do you think you actually would have yes
yeah
and you're not gay
no but you would probably
sucking somebody off
and sucking somebody out doesn't
necessarily mean that you're gay
okay because it's like
i've sucked people off before okay what
what
don't come okay come again i have okay
and um
when i was younger i was a kid yeah we
talked we talked about that so
yeah so it's not that dark i don't care
it gives a [ __ ] yeah and it's like
you know there have been
people thinking that i've been gay
people think i'm gay
it doesn't bother me yeah it doesn't
bother me but it's like if i was in
london at a club
right and i'm like you know what i mean
dancing and all of a sudden like you
know
what's his name thor cillian murphy
oh killian murphy yeah okay gail murphy
yeah murphy
and tom hardy
and i'm dancing too right and then they
were like
two guys approaching these two guys
approaching me and i'm dancing and i
start walking backwards right imagine
walking backwards all of a sudden oh
[ __ ] i'm through a door
because i'm not looking at what's behind
me right and they're still walking right
they shut the door and now you can't
hear this music as because we're in a
room
right yeah right right and then all of a
sudden but i could still and they pulled
their dicks
penises out right and i'd just be like
and i'll probably do it
you would yeah i don't believe it you
don't think i would
yeah you wouldn't just now you just now
in that look on your in your eyes
i was like wow he would you like you
don't think i would yeah because i don't
think that if i if if it came out that i
did i think it would be i'd become
famous
right sure medium bobby lee blows cilia
and tom marty in some weird room at a
club all right
and then if then i could do do a whole
thing where i'm like did it happen
right
and then it's like
there's a video maybe there's a video
camera in the room
and it just sees my style
no like we usually want to grow belongs
you you have to go can you do the sack
right but i do it voluntarily in the you
know i do it voluntarily i don't know
what's funny or this story or looking at
ryan's face while you're telling me hey
i don't know if it's uh like if it was
him i wouldn't do it right he's never
he's not tom hardy yeah i would push him
like what the [ __ ] you doing dog i mean
i might consider a handy but i'm not
sure about anywhere all right [ __ ]
talking with bobby lee these are from my
patrons my lovable patrons you have a
lot of patrons these are quick rapid
fire for you michelle k wants to know
important two-part question what's your
secret to keeping your uh mullet so
luxurious looking day in and day out i
don't have a mullet anymore
isn't that kind of a mullet no it's just
long hair let me see it
oh wow it's long yeah
you have great hair thanks man
maya p what is a misconception people
have about you
then i'm crazy
people think that i'm um
unhinged
and crazy like i
i've been to comedy clubs for the first
time
like there'll be a comedy club that like
you know that every comic has played but
for some reason i can't get a booking
and then like 10 years later i finally
get a weekend
and i'll show up i'll do the weekend and
then the owner or the manager will walk
into the green room this happened a
couple times and go
well the reason why we didn't book you
because we heard of these wild stories
but you're a really nice guy and you
know
what a great comic
and it's like i knew
you know in my head i'm like there's
these misconceptions that i'm like
wild or unhinged unhinged but it's like
i've never knocked on the show i've been
courteous to everybody i tip well i'm
nice to the staff
you know
raj where were you when you took the
greatest [ __ ] of your life
i have a feeling i know this answer
the greatest [ __ ] in my life i guess
that's what he wants to know
raj how dare you
i i i
there's one notorious [ __ ] that i [ __ ]
on the side of a guy's house
with kalila in the car screaming at me
going what the [ __ ] are you doing
and then i went
there's no [ __ ] you know bathrooms
around you right and i
i [ __ ] on a guy's house
good for you i [ __ ] in my mom's backyard
once
do you have to go real bad yeah and uh
i got up
the you know the the stuff you have in
the car in the glove compartment about
the car i took the plastic bag out and i
found some kleenex tissue and she wasn't
home and i just had a stromboli at pizza
chef pizza king in indiana and i jumped
her fence because she wasn't home and
she was supposed to be i had to and i
took a human [ __ ] right in her backyard
and the first thing i did she got home i
go mom i just [ __ ] took a [ __ ] in
your backyard she goes
i i ate a pizza king i go i ate a pizza
king stromboli i did a pizza king
strawberry and i took a [ __ ] in your
backyard and she goes
i thought we were going out for dinner
last question izzy c my question is if
bobby lee and rosie could be in any
movie or tv series duo which duo would
you all be in
oh something that's already existed
maybe yeah yeah
i think we'd be really great together i
think you and i should do a movie where
um
i was thinking about this the other day
so when you see you know how you see
like these sci-fi movies where like a
gigantic starship
right we'll get attacked
right
and
and then you're always like looking at
like whoever's the captain and people
that are in you know i mean the movie
the stars right right
and but you never know what happens to
the engineers like to two loser guys
that no one likes
that are way back in the battle of the
ship yeah the bowlership are we just you
know we're just the guys that screw this
one thing right right and so like two
guys right that are have that position
maybe a group of guys right just
complete losers the ship had this
starship has like
10 000 people on it right it gets
attacked by this you know menace alien
force right and then you we
without even the captain's order we take
we we we go into the life pods or
whatever those
you know those pet pods right and you
get out and we get out we're the only
ones alive yeah they get destroyed and
we end up on a planet right and it's a
bunch of these losers right kind of
trying to survive a great idea yeah i
mean and it's like um but somehow
we have to i don't know how to save the
day or you know i mean we become this
you know anti-heroes or whatever i don't
know what the thing is survivors yeah
but i want we
indirectly save the day by being
accidentally saved and it's our journey
it's our it's our all these episodes
would be about how these two are
adapting and all these things in their
friendship maybe one of the guys right
stole something out of like that maybe
there's an artifact right that these
alien people are trying to get one of
our loser friends finds this artifact
right then we do take these life pods
down right
and then we end up on this thing but
it's like now this gigantic evil force
is still looking for this orb or
whatever
right and joe has it like joe what the
[ __ ] you know what'd you get that joe
right that's ryan no i mean i know but
no the character's name is right right i
just [ __ ] want joe right and then you
know she was like
i just want to
make a name for myself you know i mean i
was you know i was going to go back to
earth and sell it or whatever whatever i
might be whatever and it's like now we
have we're hot you know i don't know i
like this one losers though
they they're they they they're addicted
to some alien drug
you know what you do is like
equivalent to cocaine you start on the
top of the ship like in the captain's
quarters like uh give me your you know
maybe we see the captain you see the
lieutenant you see the you think this
story is about them yeah and then you go
to the next level and it's the doctors
and like whatever yeah the medical and
then you keep going down until you reach
the bowels of the [ __ ] the like the
eighth level is like for some reason
animals right like pigs that they're
like hey kitty yeah
like right and then there's a prison
maybe there's a prison right but at the
very bottom is these
guys relegated they're like the guy the
guys that either got
demoted or right dude i love losers
we might have to cut this just because i
i think we should [ __ ] i should we
should pitch it
no
it's good you think so i really like it
i think it's hilarious don't you yeah
you have one guy who got demoted down to
to the [ __ ] level you have two guys
who've been there forever yeah best
level maybe there was a guy that worked
at like we have an artifact department
somewhere and there's a guy that got
demoted from the artifact department
like the last level like the bowels of
the thing where we have to do manual
labor right are guys that got demoted
from their positions right and we're now
down there and one of them stole our orb
or the artifact from the because he was
mad he got fired from this yeah he got
him he got fired right so he has it then
all of a sudden
we don't know but like all of a sudden
you know i mean and like i hate to say
that i like it i hate to say why and
then i'm like
i don't know maybe i was the life pod
you know whatever the escape pod i
worked in this escape pod right so you
knew i know how to get out no but no but
maybe it's like you can't use the escape
pods until like the captain unlocks it
right
because then people with a wall all the
time right but i since i'm got demoted
from there i know the code
right escape pods you know how it works
and one guy's like we're not allowed to
captain you're right and i i'm like i
know the thing you know i mean the
clearance or whatever number so we all
know and it only fits like three people
so we have to see this we have to seat
belt two people together and then one
guy's trying to get in he's like hey
guys you're like sorry kurt kurt yeah
and the door slams shut up all right
kurt this big fan he makes it somehow he
makes the sum up but he gets mad because
later in the movie we run into him in
the desert
you [ __ ] [ __ ] you left me no no we
knew the ship was gonna we knew the ship
would make it no the ship did make it
you [ __ ] and then and then when we're
escaping from the shape
the escape pods the captain can even go
you know i mean you know i mean go what
the [ __ ] somebody's accessing the you
know i mean right escape pods when i
didn't get the click you know i mean or
whatever but he's got so many things
going on and he maybe sees
three
pods escape but then it's like the the
main ship explodes they're dead
and now we're on this planet
and and it's like um
and now the the bad guys are going
you know what i mean
do you think people are still listening
no
we'll just cut that story i i i know i
don't want us to cut the story i love
the story because i think it's actually
something really funny but no because
what happens is this
is
andrew and i
made up a movie
on our podcast
called the bottoms of turtle island so
this will still be ours because we said
it on the podcast not only that that
but somebody wrote a script
based on you know
and then a production company
offered us
to do the movie
now
the money like a movie that him and i
made i mean made up
probably the budget's like three four
million dollars at least right and he
offered us two hundred fifty thousand
dollars oh yeah so we just couldn't do
it logistically but the script is okay
but like my point is is that keep it in
because what if somebody goes let's do
it
somebody who's a really good [ __ ]
writer yeah we did a really good
community
yeah really good because i'm gonna
rewrite that [ __ ] yeah yeah
but it's like a bunch of losers i love
it yeah yeah but we have to be it's i
want it to be more fear and loathing too
where it's like
we're also drug addicted and just kind
of like
scoundrels like anti-heroes yeah yeah
the world needs more anti-heroes wait
does it did you uh did you enjoy today
it was easy i would like i can do
another hour but i guess not i get tired
after an hour
okay
i really enjoyed this i don't want to
wear out my welcome or your website i'll
be back for you another year about
probably
you'll come back on every year though
won't you oh yeah one area really yeah
will i ever be on tiger belly again do
you think okay let me can i just clear
that out before we go what i i don't
know before we go i'm gonna clear it up
before i go and clear it up okay
how many times have you done it i think
three okay
the most someone who's done it is four
times
so three times on tiger belly i know
then why would you say so because i just
[ __ ] with you
but three times is like i think you're
second or third but it's been a long
time it's been like two years it's like
it's like you know i've had
dice on once tiffany haddish on once i
mean it's like a guest you know i mean
i've had aquafina on once
you know and you've been on three times
yeah that's true
stop acting a little bit yeah i'm a
little [ __ ] this is a [ __ ]
thank you for allowing me to be inside
of you bobby lee this has been a treat i
love you buddy thanks for being here
what you see is what you get with bobby
but he's growing as a human being you
could tell he's like i don't do that
anymore i don't do this anymore i you
know i'm i'm more mature
i think that he fights that like i do
it's like we know that we're older now
so we have to act a certain way but we
like to uh
yeah
you know what i mean
yeah well yeah you know i don't know
yeah no bobby is uh
yeah there's no he yeah there's no
hidden agenda there's no hidden agenda
no no no it's all about all that talk
about his dad's death talk about
um
talk about it all so thank you
bobby lee and thank you to all my top
patrons and again if you like the
podcast please please please stick
around
stick around subscribe to the show you
can watch it on youtube you can watch us
on you can listen on apple stitcher
spotify everywhere you get your podcast
um follow us the handles
at insideypodcast on the twitter or
sorry on the instagram and facebook and
at insideapod on the twitter remember uh
i'll be in denver this weekend with tom
welling in the 30th and 31st signing
autographs in la comicon on december 4th
and 5th
um but come see us in denver for sure
this weekend it's gonna be a really
great time we're spending our halloween
with you so uh and if you want to join
the lovely patreon it's it's very easy
to support the podcast you just go to
patreon.com
inside of you
and plenty of merch at the inside of
your store and all that stuff so thanks
for listening and um
you know it's been a uh
it's been a good week i'm i'm i've been
really busy ryan a lot of traveling
i have my family coming in you know i
got really upset with my mom because i'm
flying her and i'm flying her first
class for her 75th you know wow birthday
wow and the first thing she says is the
flight's too early i can't get up that
early
what do you mean you [ __ ] can't get
up that early it's first class you just
get on the plane
so that you know i feel like oh she's
going to really really be excited about
this and of course it's just like i
can't get up i have long haul covid
i'm like this is three months from now
is your flight
do you think you can go to bed at
[ __ ] 9 00 p.m and wake up at 4 30 or
5 in the morning you know people do that
it's very difficult to me
that's my mother but uh i love her you
know i guess i guess
why don't we give a shout out to the top
tier patrons uh who really helped make
this podcast possible and they give so
much and i just want to give a shout out
to all of them
nancy d leah s trisha sarah v little
lisa yukiko jill e bryan h mama lauren g
nico jerry w robert b
jason w apothean christine kristen
crook not kristin kirk kristen k that's
right emilia oh allison l raj c joshua d
emily s cjp samantha m jennifer n stacy
l gen s jamal f janelle b carrie b tap
of the 272 not to be confused with how
about the 273.
that's correct
kimberly
um
the [ __ ]
kimberly e correct
mikey l don sopremo 99 more ramirez
santiago m sarah f chad w liam p janine
r maya d maya p
maya p of course my p maddie s shannon d
belinda n kevin v james r
chris h dave h spider-man chase sheila g
brad
d ray h tab of the t liliana a turd k
also known as uh
ferguson ferguson michael s talia m
betsy d hi betsy claire m laura l chad l
rochelle nathan e marion meg cage and lp
trav l dan n lorraine g carrie h
veronica k big stevie w kendall t
and we're getting to the bottom of the
list now but we're really the top of the
list uh angel m rhiannon c corey k super
sam coleman g dev next and michelle a
liz i
um jeremy c andy t cody r sebastian k
gavinator n h
david c elliott m john b brandy d yavor
yavor
camille ass bano bono bono the c the c
joey m willie f christina e adelaide and
jeffrey m bridget a omar
l or omari
lana n and design
otg
are you down with otg design is down
with otg yeah you know me yeah you know
me hey i really appreciate you guys
listening to the podcast and um you know
i keep doing it and um hopefully you're
enjoying it and you'll spread the word
it really helps when you
spread the word force people to listen
to the podcast there's a lot of podcasts
out there and we hope you spend your uh
spend an hour with us that's all we're
asking right ryan yeah it's not much
time that's not a lot of time to ask for
no it's only
60 minutes an hour a week that's one out
of every 24 hours 24 times seven hours
in the week that's hundreds of hours and
you're only spending an hour with us
well get a job that's an hour away and
then just do the commute the commute
listen in the car you know um we love
you we love you and um from uh michael
rosenbaum here in the hollywood hills of
california i'm ryan t is in the
hollywood hills of california as well
little wave to the camera ryan bye i
love you buddy you guys have a great day
thanks for allowing me to be inside of
each and every one of you and i hope you
have a glorious freaking week do
something positive help someone out do
something for yourself
um
that's all i gotta say thank you so much
[Music]